Alright, so this is the example. This is a Bitcoin chart, but it can just work on any pair to be
very honest. Any volatile pair like your USD, GBPUSD, GBPJPY and NAS, 100 NAS, 30 and all that good stuff.
Alright, so as I mentioned, you can see that I have labeled this as a support level because we have
one, two, three, four and almost five touches, right? And if we mark it out with a rectangle box,
you can see that it's a clear support level. Alright, so a clear support level is what we are talking
about. And as you can see, I have marked this as a resistance level. So if I put this rectangle
right around here, you can see that's a clear resistance level. And also, it could be considered
as a key, key level, because you can see we had a touch here, touch here and all that good stuff.
Alright, so as I said before, now people are expecting to buy at this support level, right?
And they're going to have your stop loss somewhere around this level, all right? And they're going
to aim for the resistance. Very cool. But let's see what happens.
It stops you out. Alright, now when it stops you out, you're going to be like, okay, it's breaking
out. I think I should sell it. Alright, so you sell this right here. And then you put your stop
loss right above this level. Alright, right above the support level. And then you target somewhere
around here. Alright, or maybe this key level right around this level. Okay, so you target maybe this
level. But then guess what happens? It goes into some profit, but then see what happens. It stops
you out. So this is basically a liquidity purge. Alright, and or a fake out whatever you want to
call it. But the concept that I taught you is real. And it is not my own concept. It's actually an
ICT concept. He is the one who, you know, invented the liquidity setups and all that auto blogs and
all that good stuff. So credit where it's due. Okay, so as you can see, price just goes back up
with heavy momentum. Alright, so this is what I taught you. Price goes back up. It triggers
by orders. And then it just goes back up. As you can see, it comes back to fill some imbalance
around this area. And yeah, so it takes out the this level resistance level liquidity as well.
So a fake out. And it just goes back up and takes out the liquidity. So I hope this explains
very well that what is liquidity. And I hope that it's clear by now that liquidity comes in all
shapes and forms. Alright, so I'll give you a few more examples. So let me see if we got a few
more examples around here. So you can see that we got a, what I would say, a lower low, lower high,
lower low. Alright, so now what happens here is that, so let me go back into the replay mode. So
it's more clear. Okay, so let me go back here. So we created a lower low, lower high, lower low.
And then we're expecting as a retail trader, we are going to sell off this level, right? We're
gonna sell here. And I put our stopwatch right above that previous high. And then we're gonna
target this level maybe. Alright, and then let's see what happens. It instantly stops you out.
Alright, and now you might buy here, right, on this key level, which is this, right? And let's see
what happens. It stops you out again. Alright, so it keeps on happening. Alright, it's gonna keep
on purging the liquidity. And then what happens here? It took out all the liquidity and then it
went down to its original destination. So this is what liquidity is guys. And now I'm sure that
you might be 100% clear about liquidity. So if you are not, make sure to rewatch this video.
And let's move on to the next video.